you said the horrible things about me
saying that no man would ever sleep with
me and stuff again
something like that should never be said
to a woman
i need to hear you say sorry
i need an apology from muhammad in order
to move on totally
but with muhammad i have learned
that you only go so far with him
or he's going to blow up
if he isn't ready to apologize
i will be devastated and i probably will
cut off all ties with him
you also have to apologize for the stuff
that you said too
because you said so much about me
it's like you made me say this stuff
because i was hesitant i don't want to
talk about this kind of stuff
you started talking about it it's like
you opened it up
it's not like me started you opened it
up you should have
just said okay i don't want to talk
about this and i would never sit
when we were married muhammad used to
put
a lot of the blame on me and he's doing
it again
when you're an adult you should be able
to admit
right off the bat when you've done wrong
that to me
does show his immaturity and it's
upsetting
don't drag me into any kind of drama
again i'm trying to fix my life i know
you are
with this so please do not bring any
drama to my life anymore
hi muhammad we've never met you you know
we're her friends and we never met you
so
it's not fair for us to judge you as a
person because we don't know you
but there are no excuses for any kind of
anger or words you know what i mean
i've been through a lot
of course i regret seeing two things
because when someone gets mad
if you just say anything to make the
other person feel hurt
i'm not supposed to say that and i
regret it
sorry for saying that she's the only
person that she did like a lot of good
stuff to me
here in this country that's really good
here even even with all the fights
all the nasty stuff she did a lot of
good stuff okay and she's a good person
this is the truth
she's a hustler she's been by herself
raising four kids and
if we put all the drama stuff aside i
respect you as a person
[Music]